[Music]
the life of the bee
will be the life of our race says nikola
tesla
world famed scientist a new sex
order is coming with the female as
superior you will communicate instantly
by simple vest pocket equipment
aircraft will travel the skies unmanned
driven and guided by radio
enormous power will be transmitted great
distances without wires
earthquakes will soon become more and
more frequent temperate zones will turn
frigid
or torrid and some of these
awe-inspiring developments
says tesla are not so very far off
at 68 years of age nikola tesla sits
quietly in his study
reviewing the world that he has helped
to change foreseeing other changes that
must come
in the onward stride of the human race
from the inception of the wireless
system he says i saw that this new art
of applied electricity would be of
greater benefit to the human race than
any
other scientific discovery for it
virtually eliminates
distance the majority of the ills from
which humanity suffers are due to the
immense extent of the terrestrial globe
and the inability of individuals and
nations to come into close contact
wireless will achieve the closer contact
through transmission
of intelligence transport of our bodies
and materials and conveyance of energy
when wireless is perfectly applied the
whole earth will be converted into a
huge brain which in fact it is
all things being particles of a real and
rhythmic whole
we shall be able to communicate with one
another instantly
irrespective of distance not only this
but through television and telephones
we shall see and hear one another as
perfectly as though we were face to face
despite intervening distances of
thousands of miles
and the instruments through which we
shall be able to do this will be
amazingly simple compared with our
present telephone
a man will be able to carry one in his
vest pocket
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so great news from coco she's made her
predictions for the year 2120
100 years from now so what do you think
will happen coco
[Music]
luckily coco has more positive
predictions for this year especially if
you sign up for magellan tv our
recommendation this week is on one of
her favorite topics
rome isa is a fascinating study of six
of the most influential figures
that made rome great and that's magellan
a great place to get more context for
our videos with more than 3
000 documentaries available and you can
now take advantage of an exclusive offer
30 off an annual membership this gives
you an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even when you've joined magellan before
and lapsed you can simply click on the
link in the description to claim your
discounted membership today
thanks
mr tesla foresees great changes in our
daily life we shall be able to witness
and hear events
the inauguration of a president the
playing of a world series game
the havoc of an earthquake or the terror
of a battle just
as though we were present when the
wireless transmission of power is made
commercial
transport and transmission will be
revolutionized already motion pictures
have been transmitted by wireless over a
short distance
later the distance will be illimitable
it is more than probable that the
household's daily newspaper
will be printed wirelessly in the home
during the night
domestic management the problems of heat
light and household mechanics
will be freed from all labor through
beneficial
wireless power international boundaries
will be largely obliterated
and a great step will be made towards
the unification and harmonious existence
of the various races inhabiting the
globe
wireless will not only make possible a
supply of energy to regions however
inaccessible but it will be effective
politically
by harmonizing international interests
it will create understanding instead of
differences
[Music]
perhaps the most valuable application of
wireless energy will be the propulsion
of flying machines
which will carry no fuel and will be
free from any limitations of the present
airplanes
we shall ride from new york to europe in
a few hours
i foresee the development of the flying
machine exceeding that
of the automobile and i expect mr ford
to make large contributions towards this
progress
the problem of parking automobiles and
furnishing separate roads for commercial
and pleasure traffic
will be solved belted parking towers
will arise in our large cities
and the roads will be multiplied through
sheer necessity or finally rendered
unnecessary
when civilization exchanges wheels for
wings
the world's internal reservoirs of heat
indicated by frequent volcanic eruptions
will be tapped for industrial purposes
in an article i wrote 20 years ago i
defined the process for continuously
converting to human use
part of the heat received from the sun
by the atmosphere
my process has been carefully worked out
it is
rational
mr tesla regards the emergence of women
as one of the most profound
portents for the future it is clear to
any trained observer he says
and even to the sociologically untrained
that a new attitude towards sex
discrimination
has come over the world through the
centuries this struggle of the human
female towards sex equality will end in
a new
sex order with the female as superior
the modern woman who anticipates in
merely superficial phenomena the
advancement of her sex
is but a surface symptom of something
deeper and more potent
fermenting in the bosom of the race it
is not in the shallow physical imitation
of men that women will assert first
their equality and later
their superiority but in the awakening
of the
intellect of women the acquisition of
new fields of endeavor by women
their gradual usurpation of leadership
will dull
and finally dissipate feminine
sensibilities will choke the maternal
instinct
so that marriage and motherhood may
become abhorrent and human civilization
draw closer and closer
to the perfect civilization of the bee
the center of all bee life is the queen
she dominates the hive not through
hereditary right for any egg may be
hatched into a reigning queen
but because she is the womb of this
insect race
there are the vast desexualized armies
of workers whose sole aim and happiness
in life
is hard work it is the perfection of
communism
of socialized cooperative life wherein
all things including the young
are the property and concern of all
there are three ways by which the energy
which determines human progress can be
increased
first we may increase the mass this in
the case of humanity would mean the
improvement of living conditions health
genetic makeup etc secondly we may
reduce the frictional forces which
impede progress
such as ignorance insanity and religious
fanaticism
third we may multiply the energy of the
human mass
by enchaining the forces of the universe
like those of the sun
the ocean the winds and tides
[Music]
in the year 2100 hygiene and physical
culture will be recognized branches of
education and government
the secretary of hygiene or physical
culture will be far more important in
the cabinet of the president of the
united states who holds office in the
year 2035
than the secretary of war the pollution
of our beaches such as exists today
around new york city
will seem as unthinkable to our children
and grandchildren
as life without plumbing seems to us our
water supply
will be far more carefully supervised
and only a lunatic
will drink unsterilized water i am
convinced that within a century
coffee tea and tobacco will no longer be
in vogue
alcohol however will still be used it is
not a stimulant but a veritable
elixir of life the abolition of
stimulants will not come about
forcibly it will simply be no longer
fashionable to poison the system with
harmful ingredients
there will be enough wheat and wheat
products to feed the entire world
including the teeming millions of china
and india
now chronically on the verge of
starvation the earth is bountiful
and where her bounty fails nitrogen
drawn from the air will re-fertilize her
womb
i developed a process for this purpose
in 1900
long before the next century dawns
systematic reforestation
and the scientific management of natural
resources
will have made an end of all the
devastating droughts forest fires
and floods the universal utilization of
water power
and its long-distance transmission will
supply every household
with cheap power and will dispense with
the necessity
of burning fuel
today the most civilized countries of
the world spend a maximum of their
income on a war
and a minimum on education the 21st
century will reverse this order
it will be more glorious to fight
against ignorance than to die
on the field of battle the newspapers of
the 21st century will give a mere
stick in the back pages to accounts of
crime or political controversies
but will headline on the front pages the
proclamation
of a new scientific hypothesis
progress along such lines will be
impossible while nations persist in the
savage practice of killing each other
off
like other inventors i believed at one
time that war could be stopped by making
it
more destructive but i found that i was
mistaken i underestimated man's
combative instinct
which it will take more than a century
to breed out we cannot abolish war
by outlawing it we cannot end it by
disarming the strong
war can be stopped not by making the
strong weak
but by making every nation weak or
strong able
to defend itself i have been fortunate
enough to evolve a new idea
and to perfect means by which it can be
used chiefly
for my invention requires a large plant
but once it is established it will be
possible to destroy anything
men or machines approaching within a
radius of 200 miles
it could so to speak provide a wall of
power
offering an insuperable obstacle against
any effective aggression
if no country can be attacked
successfully there can be no purpose
in war i want to state explicitly that
this adventure of mine does not
contemplate the use of any so-called
death rays rays are not applicable
because they cannot be produced
in requisite quantities and diminish
rapidly in intensity with distance
i do not say that there may not be
several destructive wars before the
world accepts my gift
i may not live to see its acceptance but
i am convinced that a century from now
every nation will render itself immune
from attack
at present we suffer from the
derangement of our civilization
because we have not yet completely
adjusted ourselves to the machine age
the solution of our problems does not
lie in destroying but in mastering the
machine
innumerable activities still performed
by human hands today
will be performed by automatons at this
very moment scientists working in the
laboratories of american universities
are attempting to create
what has been described as a thinking
machine
i anticipated this development i
actually constructed robots
today the robot is an accepted fact but
the principle has not been pushed
far enough in the 21st century the robot
will take the place which slave labor
occupied in ancient civilization there
is no reason at all why most of this
should not come to pass in less than a
century
freeing mankind to pursue its higher
aspirations
and unless mankind's attention is too
violently diverted by external wars and
internal revolutions there is no reason
why the electric millennium should not
begin
in a few decades
[Music]
you